it's one of the most powerful sources of
energy in the known universe but how
does a zpm work welcome to Sidetrack
your Sci-Fi TV and movie channel
[Music]
a zpm or a zero point module is a
crystal structure about really big
[Music]
hello hello
that can generate or create massive
amounts of energy
just one of these things aboard Atlantis
powered the shields for tens of
thousands of years while it was under
water
it has been known that the zpm can
generate massive amounts of energies for
millions of years until it becomes
depleted but how does the damn thing
work well I've had a little bit of a
look and scratched my head a lot at
actual real science to try and explain
it but I'm also going to talk about how
it's explained in the Stargate series
itself it extracts vacuum energy from
this artificial region of Subspace time
until it reaches maximum entropy so
let's break that down a little bit so
vacuum energy from an artificial region
of Subspace until it reaches maximum
entropy right vacuum energy now there is
a thing in science I'm going to talk
about in a couple of minutes called Zero
Point Energy now this is energy that
comes from the quantum realm basically
an artificial region of Subspace so it
would seem that the Ancients were able
to create an artificial region of
Subspace within the zero point module
now I'm assuming that's what it means
that this is a small pocket of Subspace
folded within the actual Crystal
but it could also mean that the Ancients
were able to actually create an
artificial Subspace that filled the
entire galaxy and that the zero point
modules just tap into that
but I think my first point is probably
valid and that it's a pocket of Subspace
within the crystal itself because the
crystals can eventually become depleted
if it was just a plug a plug into a
artificial Subspace that filled the
entire universe an actual Subspace
then they wouldn't become depleted one
day they would just tap into that and
they would just be able to feed off it
constantly unless they fed off the
constantly until the crystal itself
actually lost the ability to tap into
Subspace that's possible the other
probably more likely option like I said
is that it's actually a pocket of
Subspace within the crystal structure it
can draw off energy and that until it
reaches this maximum entropy now entropy
is a little bit difficult to understand
because I Googled it because I didn't
know what the word meant and it
basically means an increase in
randomness
so I'm going to take from that
um and this is something that actually
is a word to use a great deal in
thermodynamics I am going to take from
this to me that an increase of
Randomness means that
when you're drawing energy out of his
EPM there is a structure to the Subspace
field
and the the more energy you draw from
that the more scrambled it gets and the
more scrambled it gets eventually you
can't draw energy from it anymore so it
becomes depleted so it's not really like
a battery losing energy it's more like
petrol getting all gloopy if it gets too
cold and Frozen and doesn't can't burn
it because it's all there
um
maybe I'm sure that somebody in the
comments will come up with a much better
metaphor than that
so obviously we know that even just one
zpm can power a lot of ancient
technology and create weapon systems
that have been able to defend that
planet more than once
okay
try it now
[Music]
but how much of the actual technobabble
of the Zero Point Energy Etc is based on
any sort of reality and how much energy
would we be talking
[Music]
[Music]
well we do have something from our own
physicists to sort of Base an opinion on
we have the kardashev scale if you
haven't subscribed already please do and
like and share the video wherever the
hell you want also if you enjoy the
content and you want to support the
Channel please hit the join button also
we have our sister Channel Sidetrack
sides where we do lots of little best
bits from the lives and lots of other
fun silly little videos so please go and
subscribe to science
so this Russian physicist created these
levels and he based these civilization
levels on their ability to use the
energy that they have available to them
now our civilization day hasn't even
quite made level one we are actually
still Level zero so what are these
different levels well this type one and
that's the ability for any civilization
to use all of the energy that reaches it
from its Sun so basically all of the
energy from the Sun that we could
physically capture if we were able to
cover the entire planet with solar
panels that's basically type one now
obviously we don't get most of our
energy from solar panels we burn fossil
fuels we use nuclear energy and so on
and so on but to reach type 1 you only
actually have to be able to generate the
equivalent to amount of energy that
equivalent amount of energy is estimated
at 2 times 10 to the power of 17 Watts
that's a lot but in 2020 we actually
generated 2 times 10 to the power of 13
Watts which actually isn't far off
it's estimated that anything from 100 to
200 years depending on whether certain
Technologies come to the fork like
Fusion Energy we might be able to reach
type 1 civilization but a type 2
civilization is a bit of a leap so that
is being able to use or utilize all of
the energy being generated from your
local star so that has been able to
capture all the energy that the sun
generates not just a little bit that
lands on Earth how much energy is that 4
times 10 to the power of 26 Watts which
is again a very big number that I've
can't quite imagine but it's a lot of
light bulbs now if you're a Tracker
you'll remember something called the
Dyson Sphere now this is a theoretical
object that you can actually build
around the Sun in the 20th century a
physicist called Freeman Dyson
postulated the theory that an enormous
Hollow sphere could be constructed
around a star
this would have the advantage of
harnessing all the radiant energy of
that star but obviously it'd be quite a
big structure just go and Google how big
the sun is for a second the theory is
though that if you could build a Dyson
Sphere your civilization would have
almost unlimited energy it would never
need any other sort of power source but
could have a constant energy source from
the Sun how long until we could reach
that sort of level
well we're not going to build a Dyson
Sphere but we could potentially generate
that much electricity and we might be
able to get there in the next 100 000
years type three that is your ability to
absorb or use all of the energy
generated by your entire galaxy right
now that is a crap load of energy I
don't even have an estimate for how much
energy that is it's based roughly on the
Luminosity of all the stars that we can
see but ugh it's it's a very very large
number now Michio Kaku in his book
hyperspace and parallel worlds actually
suggested a fourth type of civilization
the Type 4 was able to absorb or use the
energy from extra dimensional sources
Dark Matter Subspace and so on and so on
so if we are going to put the Ancients
on this scale they will actually be a
Type 4 civilization because they had
learned how to absorb or use energy from
an extra dimensional Source a Subspace
bubble but what exactly is zpe or Zero
Point Energy because that's what we're
talking about I assume they mean from a
zero point module well Zero Point Energy
is the lowest form of energy in the
quantum scale so even when atoms and
everything that make up the universe are
completely at Absolute Zero they still
have some energy and that energy is
called Zero Point Energy this means that
actually even at Absolute Zero atoms and
things still move around a little bit
this leads into a problem with sort of
the Transporters again if you're
tracking you might have heard of
something called the Heisenberg
compensator foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh my God
that comes from the Heisenberg
uncertainty principle in that that
whenever you look at an atom you can't
exactly know where it is because by the
time you've looked at it it's already
moved that's because it has zero point
energy and regardless of its state it
will always have some motion so when the
Transporters aboard the Enterprise
wanted to lock onto all your atoms and
beam them to another place it can't
because it can never tell you exactly
where those atoms are because they're
always moving by the time you've looked
at it it's already moved so it has the
Heisenberg compensator to compensate for
that fluctuation and to allow the
Transporters to work this is one of
always my favorite things in Star Trek
and it's proper sci-fi technobabble
somebody points out that you can't do
that because of the Heisenberg and
sensitive principle so starter just goes
yeah we gotta compensator
but how powerful could this Zero Point
Energy actually be well scientists
Richard fireman and John Wheeler did a
little bit of math and they suggest to
that all of the matter within a light
bulb if we could absorb the Zero Point
Energy from that would be enough to boil
all of the oceans on the planet
so that is quite a lot of energy and
really would be the ultimate goal we
today are trying to harness the power of
the Sun by creating Fusion Energy but
really if we could tap into Zero Point
Energy in some way
energy from a Quantum level even a
minute amount of material could generate
enough electricity to power our entire
civilization and would catapult us to a
Type 4 civilization but there's a small
problem
Zero Point Energy is not very well
understood in physics and actually the
Heisenberg uncertainty principle leads
into some of the biggest problems in
quantum mechanics it's not really well
understood and for one scientist that
says this actually could generate
massive amount of electricity and that
Zero Point Energy could be actually more
powerful than any other of the radiation
or electrodes or magnetic energies there
are other scientists that say no it
isn't and it wouldn't be able to
generate any energy and the vacuum
energy from a zpm wouldn't even power a
light bulb
so
for now the science doesn't quite agree
but at very least in Stargate the zpm is
the king if you want Power you want a
crystal structure about that big that
just plugs in and generates your shields
for 10 000 years
what is it you call them
PM 0.1
they're designed to operate in parallel
all three providing part of the city
simultaneously however used in sequence
it may be possible to sustain the
necessary power for the needed time
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
if you want to become a fully fledged
side Trekker and you really enjoy the
content hit the join Button as always
please stay safe and I'll see you next
time
[Music]